dude you're the talker of the town happy
new year
happy new year andy covert
is that what you call yeah
now there are some cnn staffers they're
angry with cnn because they put you on
new year's eve trunk
you're quoting
unnamed sources yes of course i would
i'm asking you have you heard these
rumblings well you know many people are
saying that i should run for mayor i'm
not mayor of what
yes well i'm saying if we're quoting
unnamed sources that we're making up
then i'm making up other things that
people are saying
listen i will not be shamed for having
fun right on new year's eve that's why
i'm there
that's why they bring me there it's a
four and a half hour show
i know
started kicking in
around 11 30. so everyone's focusing on
kind of the last 45 minutes or hour that
we were on the air i kicked into high
gear with 45 minutes left so we had done
15 interviews before that point you know
i won't be ashamed for it i had a blast
anderson had a blast we left and we were
like that was fun what a fun new year's
eve now i saw for my drinking on new
year's eve none no nobody said anything
to you at cnn the only direction that i
get every year from jeff zucker is
have
fun
um there you go and that is nice that is
my job it was not only a middling year
but it ended in a car crash of covid and
betty white dying on the day of new
year's eve who everyone loved so it was
like we gotta kick it into gear we gotta
have fun a lot of people are home
spending their evenings with us when you
viciously attacked ryan seacrest new
year's eve
did you uh were you concerned about your
relationship with kelly ripa who
who is one of your best friends have you
heard from her is ryan seacrest
as i was going on my rant of a journey i
did wind up kind of starting to throw
abc under the bus and that is my only
regret from the night because i really
like ryan seacrest he's a really nice
guy and i was
as they say in my cups and i was kind of
enjoying the rant i was like wow it's
really fun being on cnn just ranting
like a nutty guy this is fun so
i kept going and uh that i felt bad
about that i felt bad about and i texted
ryan uh the next morning oh you were
terrific listen i applaud anybody who
gets on there and isn't so politically
correct you know that that's my thing
you're the kid absolutely i love it by
the way here's another thing that i
regret towards the end of the de blasio
rant i said something like it i have a
feeling i'll be here next year and when
i saw the clip i was like dude
that's the clip they're gonna play when
you get canceled this year they're gonna
be like i guess he's not gonna be there
next year although cnn announced
yesterday i'm coming back next year so i
was happy for that andy what is it about
anderson cooper that keeps you from
falling in love with him if i can be
serious for a minute seriously what is
it that keeps me from falling yeah
listen i just think it's not what our
relationship is based on
we're just friends
that's not a part of it i think at this
point we know each other too well we're
not attracted to each other in that way
is it the white hair maybe because it
ages him maybe
no yeah no it's just he's just not your
thing no he's a handsome guy he's a
handsome guy
i think he modeled when he was young
maybe
yes he did now he didn't die what can i
tell you we're not in that place we're
not in that place